hello there today i'm talking to adi
fuchs who is an expert in ai
acceleration technology
we talk about a whole bunch of things in
this interview but it is a little bit of
a special thing because it's not about a
paper or anything but it is about a
series of blog posts that adi has
authored i am very much a noob in the ai
accelerator field so i thought it'd be
really cool to talk to someone who
really know what they're talking about
who are in this industry and can explain
everything you know from very technical
to to very nubish for me so we go over a
whole bunch of things like why do we
even need accelerators what are the
reasons behind it uh why are gpus here
and why are they good for ai up to very
very modern approaches to ai
accelerations tpus and and beyond that
so if you're interested in this uh watch
the interview it was very cool i learned
a lot and i hope you do too
without further ado uh
have fun
[Music]
hello everyone today i have adi fuchs
with me right here he is the author of a
series on medium called ai accelerators
and i have noticed in the last few
years and certainly months that i have
no clue about hardware i my conception
of hardware is something that goes
and if i want a neural network i need
like a gpu that goes
and then there's tpus and then there's
ipus and there's lots of stuff but i
never had any clue what any of it meant
so this article series was really
valuable to me and
i thought maybe it's valuable to some of
you too so adi thank you very much for
being here yeah thanks for having me and
thanks for you know the kind
introduction
um can you tell us a little bit about
how you know what your background is in
this space uh why did you why did you
decide to write a series like this and
why did you think that um you know you
you had the knowledge to do so
well so i've been back and forth between
i would say industry and academia
i've been working for several hardware
and software companies you know phillips
i also worked for melanox i also worked
for apple for some you know short period
and i've been back and forth i did my
masters back in israel and then i did my
phd at the us at the princeton
university
and i i always you know my my
studies have been only mainly focused on
computer architecture
you know more recently my experience has
been with computer architectures
processor architectures in general
there's a lot of software going on into
it but you know from the architectural
perspective is how you can
design systems that are
that can
execute these
applications very efficiently and
there's a myriad way of actually doing
so so
um after my studies i started working
for one of the big companies um in the
landscape
and i said actually actually when i
graduated
i had when i graduated my phd i always
had in my in the back of my mind that
ai and machine learning and deep
learning
all that has been very very exciting you
know i took just like one or two classes
but i didn't really have
any extensive experience in it but i do
feel like i do i i was able to see that
potential
and i wanted to say okay
one of the natural things for me after i
graduate would be to work for one of
those companies that are developing
hardware for ai
but uh you know it the story goes well
beyond just hardware you know people
right now understand that they need to
develop smart systems smart software it
needs to be a full stack view just going
beyond just like you said like the the
gpu that goes before the tpu or or the
underlying process or whatnot so
the landscape seemed to be very exciting
it's rapidly evolving there are a lot of
solutions out there
and i thought that
you know as a hobby
what i did it's just started as a hobby
and you're just
observing what people are doing
trying to look at the competitive
landscape and try to see if there's
anything that could be interesting for
someone that
wants to know more about that world
either be it a research scientist that
wants to know a little bit of what's
going on under the hood
or people that are hardware engineers
that wants to know a little bit more
about you know the high level motivation
for why people are doing ai accelerators
so
i was hoping that i will be able to
create something like that
that will be able to contribute to
several types of uh people i would say
very cool uh you so my question is a
little bit
why what does it even mean to build
hardware for something like obviously
you know we have computers and i can you
know i can do pretty much anything with
it with a computer what does it mean
to
to
to say make hardware for ai uh you have
this term of user to hardware
expressiveness what does that mean
so
i would say it's
i would as i said there is it's more of
my term in lack of a better term i would
say that probably people have several
either academic or industry more
accurate
ways to depict this is that the user
knows on the high level what they're
doing what they want to do what type of
models they want to explore
and
how they translate it to high-level code
you know like cafe pie torch tensorflow
and all that so the research scientist
has
the big model that they want to explore
but under the hood
there is what the hardware understand it
what it can execute
so if you look at it you can see that
there is a lot of layers that you need
to go
to that you need to lower from the high
level code all the way to the you know
to the bits that are basically executing
on on on you know that the electrons
that are flowing
and it gets really really complex
because you need to have a full stack
view
and really know
whatever crazy idea that the user is
doing
and whatever and
and the last low level detail of
everything that your hardware basically
can can execute you know either degrees
of parallelism how it accesses the
memory
be it dram high bandwidth memories hbms
there's a there's a lot of things that
are going on how your
what are your precisions are you doing
fp32 are you doing fp16 bf16 are you
doing integers what is your bit width
and and there are a lot of
details that someone needs to understand
in order to build a full flesh
fully capable compiler stack
that you can basically write whatever
you can think of and it'll out of the
box be not only working because as you
said
you can basically compute everything
right i don't have church touring thesis
a computer is a computer
but there is a difference between just
solving the problem mathematically or
accurately and actually doing it
performance in in a performant fashion
because
you can either solve a single problem
and it will take a month to run or you
can solve the same problem and it will
be more efficient it can take i don't
know like a few hours or even a few
minutes
so
that's that's the idea of user to
hardware expressiveness you know the
user can think of whatever and the
hardware can execute whatever and you
need to bridge that semantic gap between
them and okay and
okay let's say we agree that we need to
to build hardware uh for ai you go
through a little bit of the history of
that i guess starting with what everyone
knows which is kind of moore's law uh
that processors or number of transistors
increased over time in an exponential
fashion but then you go into some into
some less known laws like denard scaling
all of this leading up to
saying you know we've reached the end of
clock frequency i think this is also
known um what's also known is probably
that
the
we have replaced essentially speed with
number of cores and we're going to
parallelism now you draw an excellent
comparison to gpus here gpus being the
current uh super many core architectures
or not current but in the history they
had more cores uh what makes gpus
um
so attractive for ai in the first place
yes
so this i think this goes back a little
bit to more of the intro you know you're
just saying hardware and you're saying
computer but
the fact that you can compute things at
certain speeds
have been key enablers i go in the
introduction i'm talking about alexnet
right you see in the alex net paper they
say in the abstract we were able to
develop a gpu implementation an
efficient gpu implementation that allows
it that allowed us to number to crunch a
lot of data
and train a lot of data within a
reasonable time frame and get a super
fancy model that can run efficiently and
in within reasonable times and that
basically was a key enabler what i
didn't even mention is that
for
example for natural language processing
the same story happened if you look at
the attention is all you need paper
they were able to say in the abstract we
were able to train it on gpu for three
and a half days which was order of
magnitude faster than previous solution
you know all those
lsdns and rnns that have this interim
sequential part that we were able to
devise a new architecture that is able
to run on hardware and just by
being able to harness the power of gpus
we were able to run and it basically
unlocked our capabilities so the ability
of hardware has been
the role of hardware has been very
significant and basically being the key
enabler of of of ai capabilities and
that's why i think this series is more
is is very important
going back to our discussion you know
trying to talk about frequency it's good
to know about the history because when
you're talking about ai accelerators
is is essentially why do we need
accelerators why why and why now
so
as you can see as we said at the
beginning there was there was frequency
we were able to get our our circuitry
going faster you can say that okay we
have we back at the 90s you can have
like this 486 going at 33 megahertz all
the way to like 100 megahertz then it
came the pentiums and people say yeah i
have like under like 300 megahertz and
then you go to like a gigahertz and then
it all ultimately going to the
pentium 4 with like three or four
gigahertz back at the time you know
during that time people understood
that
because you're not able to do dinar
scaling you know that the gnar scaling
what i mentioned there is the actual
real problem you know going beyond
moore's law the north scaling says that
it's not only that you can have smaller
transistors they can also go faster
and you can cram more transistors and
you can have like if you're if your
dimension scales by k
you can have k to the squared number of
transistors each one will be k faster
and your and the key enabler there was
that you were able to you know to lower
the voltage by that factor
the thing is back in the night back into
2000 the voltage stops scaling at the
rate that you were able to
increase the frequency so you can get
faster circuitry but your power density
essentially increases and that's where
you can see that the graph that
increases and then people say okay we
cannot have faster transistors so that
was the first stage in the evolution
cannot have faster transistors you can
see like the green
dotted that dot is basically plateauing
and say we cannot we so the implication
is that we cannot have a single task
going
faster
but as moore's law is saying we can
still have more transistors they just
cannot go faster so
instead of having one task going fast
we're going to have multiple tasks
going at the same speed so instead of
you know increasing the frequency twice
we'll have twice the number of cores and
depending on how we can map the problem
how efficiently we can map the problem
we'll be able to still get
um 2x by essentially parallelizing
and that was phase two which is
essentially the multi-core era
so you're able to cram more transistors
they'll be able to getting on the same
silicon wafer or or the same silicon die
you'll be able to get
um twice as many cores and as you can
see here the green line especially for
gpus as uh
as the main beneficient you're getting
you're saying
let's develop these instead of having
this design which is the cpu which has
all sorts of very sophisticated
mechanisms like stuff that there are
branch predictors
prefetchers and all these speculative
things that are saying we can
execute an instruction but this will
take too long we can do out of order
execution doing all sorts of tricks to
make a single
stream of instruction go fast instead of
it let's do let's
redevise
our software a little bit
and break these the stream of
instruction to several independent
stream of instructions that are called
threads and we're going to be able to
run them hopefully in a perfectly
parallel fashion on different
what we call cores and each core will
will execute its own stream of
instructions so essentially we'll break
up one task into multiple sub tasks and
by that we'll be able to still
get the same degree of speed up you know
if we'll be able to get it
to to be able to get like 2x tasks we'll
be able to get a speed up of 2x
obviously there's a lot of difficulties
but
that's that's that's the main idea so
we'll be able to so eventually if we
have enough parallelism we'll be able to
get to you know hundreds or even
thousands of cores
and we'll be able to get hundreds of
thousands of speed up you know compared
to our regular task
but at the mid i would say the beginning
of the 2000 around 2010 and 2011 there
were two different works that
highlighted the same phenomenon as
meaning that
you know because the north scaling again
we're not able to scale the voltage
just having transistors powered not even
doing computation it doesn't matter even
at what speed
just having them powered on
will increase our power density meaning
moore's law is still working we can
still shrink down the transistors we can
still cram more and more cores into the
same
silicon
square
square millimeter you know in the same
skeleton area we'll be able to to get
more cores but
the power at that time will not remain
constant so the power also increases
so that will be unsustainable and this
created the phenomena that these works
are talking about that is called either
the utilization wall or dark silicon
yeah that it means that you know you can
have
let's say a mil it doesn't matter that
you're gonna have a million core with
micro transistors it means that not all
cores can be turned on at the same time
meaning for the purpose of your
computation you're going to remain in
under a fixed budget
just due to power constraints
so basically what it means that you're
not going to be able to get more
transistors and at this point that the
power constraints are mainly due to us
not being able to cool down
a
like a thing that consumes more power
yeah or what what are the constraints
there so the constraints is that the
power density the power density
you know the watt per millimeter square
just starts growing exponentially as you
start exponentially cramming more
transistors because
the power per transistor stops scaling
it remains constant so you'll have 1000x
transistors you'll have 1000x the power
and that creates a problem that will be
unsysted and and that will require
cooling
that either does not exist or is
super expensive to manufacture so yeah
and that created a problem that
essentially says that okay we're not
going to be able to get more transistors
so if you're not going to be able to get
more transistors
then came the notion of building
accelerators
meaning that instead of having a single
piece of silicon solving a wide range of
problems
you're going to be focused on a little
bit of a narrow scope
of
certain applications and those
application needs to have some
properties so um and that's the idea if
we're not going to get get more
transistors we're going to be able to
create smart uh
purpose-built circuitry
with purpose-built compute and memory
and communication that is basically
targeting specific problems
you can see an example like video
encoders bitcoin miners
and ai yep
so you can see there if if you look at
you know more general purpose processors
if you can look at power efficiency or
even performance you can see that the
general purpose processor
is is fairly does fairly well for a wide
application range
but those accelerators
are you know for for example for ffd
or or or uh you know graphs or or or
matrix multiply they're really good at a
certain they're a certain task but they
do really poorly on on something else
for example you cannot run your
operating system or or you cannot it
wouldn't be recommended for you to run
your operating system on an ai
accelerator
so well wait wait wait just wait
like the community's going to figure it
out you just need to scale enough but i
guess i i think from this point on it's
it's sort of common let's say common
knowledge again that you know gpus uh
were purpose built for graphics but
inherently that meant kind of matrix
multiply things together and then on the
other hand deep neural networks uh just
by happenstance uh by you know being
convnets or or feed forward networks
also using a lot of matrix multiplies
and
i guess that was just you know how the
universe works these things came
together and that was just a really neat
fit and
the point though is
the gpus weren't made for ai in the
first place even though it seems to be
like a really good application for them
uh how
you know what's what's
gpus are good for ai but
what can be even better right like in
which in which places are gpus still sub
optimal for the ai things that we are
doing well it really depends on on your
applications demands and the application
scopes for example
you can see like in the in the map that
you're showing here you can see that
gpus
are really good at flexibility and
they're really good in in in having
matrix multiply as you can say linear
algebra is is something that gpus do
pretty well
and if you can map
a lot of these problems
like a lot of cons
and and and uh you know recommender
models and all that you can map them
into a gpu and do dents and do dense
linear algebra pretty well
that will give you a
fairly good
boost
but if you would could devise a certain
you know if you would go all the way to
the efficiency and doing something
really really specialized
you'll be able to say let's develop an
accelerator that just does resnet for
example that'll be really really
contrived to collapse to a certain
a certain type of network
theoretically everything will be
hardwired even the weights and
everything will be perfectly perfectly
fit
for that
but it would not be able to execute
anything else so if you if you would be
yeah
it will be very very bad in doing other
more general purpose ai so that comes
the question you know what how can you
trade flexibility for efficiency
for example one of the things that um
some of the companies are are are
that are not gpu based companies
are tackling
are these
big these large language models for
example those gpt3s and all that
and gpus if you look at the a100s
you can see that gpus
from the and from for i would say that
it was a conscious engineering decision
for nvidia to go for high bandwidth
models uh high bandwidth memories i'm
sorry
that
are basically fast memories but are
limited in
capacity alternatively you can go for
something else you can go for a slower
dram based memory so hbms are fast but
they're limited in capacity and drams
are huge and have like
terabytes versus you know dozens of
gigabytes and if your model requires
terabytes of data you would need
hundreds or even thousands of gpus just
to be able to have the same to do
everything in memory you know to have
the same to map the memory space
of your model
and that would be something that
you know i'm not saying that gpus can do
but it would require a lot of
gpus turned on and a lot of power and a
lot of communication going from
diff from different gpu systems
to be able to uh train a single um you
know like
hundreds or hundreds of billions of
parameter model so
i mean that's exactly what we see right
right
okay um so
yeah i guess we can we can just
dive into
what kind of you know hardware that goes
beyond gpus exists that is to say in
part three
okay
in part three of your series you go into
a little bit of the um architectural
sorry foundations
and you describe kind of what what
exists you know what instruction sets
are uh what kind of models exist for
example reconfigurable processors uh you
you you make sort of a good
very extensive background overview which
we're going to skip right now uh just
due to time i just found this very very
funny i guess that's why you posted it
here yeah so there is this is a single
instruction on that i can use on an
intel processor that computes
approximations to the rep reciprocal
square root with less than 2 to the
negative 28 the relative error of the
pack double precision floating point
values from these things
and stores the result in that thing with
right mask a1 that is excellent like i i
i need i need that instruction every day
yeah so
yeah depending on the way that that this
is basically showing how you can devise
when you look at a processor you know
the traditional uh the traditional model
of processor is called a phenomenon
model it's you're saying that you're you
have a processor your processor accesses
the memory your processor
fetches an instruction from the memory
it decodes the instruction and says oh
yeah we should do this and that so this
instruction accesses the memory and
loads let's fetch the next instruction
and all and all that
so the the instructions are basically
built from an isa which is the
instruction set architecture which you
can think about it is the vocabulary in
which the uh the processor says that the
processor supports some processors
support x86 and processor support arm
and so which uh which is i would say
like
the x86 is an example of what we call a
complex instruction set uh computing or
cisc and arm is the risk
so there was a trade-off between
you know how much you're going to be
able to uh to have a single instruction
you know compact nicely which will take
less memory so you're going to have a
large vocabulary to express more complex
computation versus
uh the risk you the reduced instruction
set computer in like arm that it's going
to basically be translated to a lot of
lot of micro instructions that are be
that will be simpler so that was an
ongoing discussion but you know this you
know this gives a background of how
basically a processor works
so yeah there are a lot of concepts that
i showed at the part three that were
basically
used as the background for part four you
know historically i wrote part four as
the combination of part three and part
four but someone said but you know a lot
of people just advised me that this is
just gonna be
super long so i needed to break it down
so
yeah so if if anyone if anyone wants
wants the background this article is is
really nice on sort of the foundations
of all of this if you if you want that
and i think people can relate a little
bit because in nlp you have this whole
tokenization problem of you know how big
do you make your vocabulary and if you
make it too small you're gonna have to
break down stuff into smaller pieces and
so on um just i think it's it's
approximately the the same
concept right here you're trading
essentially memory for
for uh for speed
and and also the the thing is that you
need a difficult
you need a very smart compiler
to look at your code and say okay these
sequence of if for example if you're
writing in c so these sequence of
instructions are going to be translated
all to that single instruction
and that way you'll have a smart and
very very complex compiler will be able
to map your sequence of operation into
that sometimes it works and sometimes
you're just going to have like these
ghost instructions that no one's really
going to use
so so here in part four i think that
that is it is the longest part and you
dive into the various uh companies
startups that exist today building ai
ai accelerators or ai hardware in any
form
and it is we have to say that you are
associated with one of those companies
we're not going to say which one though
obviously with the best one um
but uh
i felt i felt reading the article that
there was no there was no
i i didn't feel any favoritism so i was
i was pretty happy to see that now we
have a lot of them even discussed in
your articles do you maybe have some
that you to you know want to highlight
in particular to just maybe show the
diversity of the field and and where
it's going yes so while there are a lot
of solutions out there
i would say most of them
stem from a handful of of of a few
architectural ideas that were
highlighted in in part three
so i would say that there is
originally there's the gpu with the cuda
that has dense linear algebra that is
basically has this uh model this
execution model single instruction
multiple thread
it's the idea of the the classical
phenomenon model you have instructions
they're translated to processor level
isa that the instruction said
architecture that nvidia gpus understand
and it's being parallelized and it and
you know it has all these
uh you know systolic-like execution
and a systolic array is is an idea that
dates back to the 1970s where you're
going to have a single piece of hardware
that is really good in doing matrix
multiply because the data when you're
doing matrix multiply the data from the
a and the b matrix is basically flowing
like that and if you have a very smart
circuitry like that which is
in a sense a smart arc accelerator like
engine just for matrix multiply it'll be
able to carry out matrix multiply
really efficiently so
yeah so the gpus have that and you can
say that
there are some other companies that
i would say that are in the camp of
via light a combination of what we call
a vliw a very large instruction word
where you're going to have a
heterogeneous
array of compute machines like a memory
compute machine a vector compute machine
a matrix multiply and maybe you know
some sort of a linear
uh compute machine for your reuse or or
or tangents
operators and whatnot then you have a
static compiler that basically creates
this huge instruction that says okay
this data goes to the vector unit this
data goes to the matrix multiply and
this goes to the uh vector unit and
you're able to and you know the timing
of all these units and you'll be able to
have a smart compiler that statically
um
creates this single word that is going
to be fed to all of them so you can have
us
at compile time a smart compiler that
will be able to
efficiently schedule these
um
different data or operands to these
machines and they will be able to get
really efficient execution so for
i would say the systolic slash vliw camp
i would say
things that are i would
arguably the most uh famous example is
the google's tpu that was presented at i
would say
mid 2017 at an at a conference called
the iska the instruction uh the
international
symposium of computer architecture which
is the biggest computer architecture uh
conference
so they
showed a model that is basically the tpu
is based on a big systolic array
execution
with a linear unit
and this smart memory and everything is
being fed and they have a smart compiler
that translates ai code
for
that is ablex to execute dnns these
um deep neural nets and that was
the first time arguably
the most famous
non-gpu ai accelerator that was
uh presented
so you can have you have the google
uh tpu you also have a startup that is
called grok
some of its found uh some of its
founding members were part of the google
tpu team there were architects at google
that
took parts of that
that took some of the ideas
of google's tpu and and created a more
commercialized
accelerator
for uh deep neural nets
um
and also there is habana so i would say
google
uh grok and habana are
i would say the camp
vliw plus
systolic array um
uh accelerators
so yeah and so i understand this
correctly they essentially they have a a
a chip or a a board and that has many
different let's say sub chips on it one
is really good at matrix multiplying one
is really good at doing relu one is
really good at whatever soft max so kind
of all these operations that we need in
ai they have like specially sub sub
chips for and then they have a very
smart essentially router that says okay
you go here you go here you go here so
you know i could compute
let's say i could compute the last
layers relu at the same time or the last
batches relu at the same time that i
compute this layers uh forward through a
linear layer
is that yeah this is essentially
basically pipelining it so
if you have like one thing that needs to
rail you and then
one thing that needs the you know the
matrix multiplied for the kind of
operation then it needs to reload and
then you can feed the next sample or
whatnot that uses the matrix multiplier
while the the other one also already
doing relu so you can do like sort of a
pipeline execution and by that you're
basically filling up your
your compute uh machines right your your
you're
and by that you're getting better
utilization because you're using all of
your hardware at a single point and
you're and everybody's happy and your
architecture is perfectly balanced
because your compiler is smart enough to
understand the program
yeah so essentially we're we're saying
we want the purpose-built hardware like
the the unit that just does relu because
that's way better than having a cpu do
relu
but in order to have the flexibility we
have a bunch of them on a chip and then
we have a router and the compiler that
knows how to use that router uh and the
pipeline yes
okay excellent um so but that it seems
really it's it seems like just from from
me now it seems a little bit still in
the spirit of like a gpu of what you
said that you you essentially have this
von neumann model um except here there's
sort of pipelining added there is
distribution to different sub units
added right but it's still
these kind of instructions
that are in sequence and the compiler
needs to understand how to translate a
program into that and as i understand
the other companies here they're trying
to go sort of
a bit more out of like out of that
paradigm is that correct so i would say
the other big directions that companies
are doing
is the data flow directions so some
companies are combining
two elements one is called
reconfigurability
and the other one is called data flow so
um the their reconfigurable data flow i
think that tents torrents are doing it i
think that sambanova is doing it
uh originally there was a company called
wave computing that did it
um
that are and and uh there is another
company there was another company called
simple machines that are doing it so the
idea of reconfigurable data flow is that
first of all if you look at a um
pi torch or tensorflow keras or or cafe
program and ai a
deep learning
application you can see that there are
different layers
and they're communicating with each
other so you have a unknown a
predetermined set of operands
and you know how the data is basically
uh
being communicated between different
parts of your graph
so in the underlying computation the
underlying computation is basically
constructing of a
computation graph what does that mean
like you can see over there you have
your layer
and from that you have another layer
that does really and then you feed it to
another kind of layer
or waste and do that so you have
basically something that is not
instruction level but basically more of
the way that your data
you know your you can see that your data
is basically flowing between different
layers
so the idea is that instead of having
that data that program that data flow
communication graph go you flatten it to
the classic fondoment model then you try
to re-parallelize it you can start off
from this data flow model from this data
flow graph and you can basically
statically map it
via another again you need a smart
compiler to do that as well you need to
map it to your existing to a specialized
hardware that is capable of executing
data flow meaning you can have a compute
element that does
multiply in here and you can have
another one that does add in here and
you can have
you can basically break down your dense
linear algebra to compute unit and you
can feed them to other compute unit
instead of
you know breaking down your computation
to micro unit like saying oh here's an
add then oh you need to multiply and all
that so
it would be more natural to look at the
compute um
looking at the computation graph as a
data flow graph and map it to the
hardware and you can start it instead of
you know going back and forth
flattening it to the funeral and then
re-parallelizing it to the funeral so
they're you know these companies bets
are that
this model is more natural it's more
hardware friendly and ultimately you can
have
you can get a better gain because you're
able to
have a better more complex understanding
of the graph you can look at different
elements in your graph you can have a
smart compiler that fully understands
your hardware it knows the underlying
the number of compute elements and what
each compute element in your processor
in your accelerator is doing and from
that it will create a mapping that will
essentially go be very static and your
data is just going to flow instead of
you needing to manually orchestrate it
and breaking it down to instructions so
you know one of the main selling points
of
the existing landscape like gpus is that
gpus are
they have a very mature software stack
and they're very flexible you can
program everything from that fundament
model if you can create
a flexible enough architecture
you'll be able to
basically
handle
new models
because you know the main challenge for
you to build a an accelerator company is
that it takes two or three years to tape
out a chip meaning you need to think
about your idea you need to think about
your architecture
all of what you can execute
and you need to be generic enough
because within two or three years you're
it's possible that your application has
completely shifted away and if you look
at those
uh the if at the
mapping of specialized accelerators if
you're here
but your application space is moved here
you're going to be you're not going to
be able to execute it efficiently
so
you need to be very open-minded and you
need to be very mindful about being
flexible enough to support this one of
the main challenges for that is the
ability to create um
a smart enough software stack that will
be able to execute it so it's not a
trivial task so
you can take the wave computing uh case
as an example
you know wave computing was a company
that was really revolutionary they were
able to
they were able to present a commercial
uh commercialized
accelerator that does reconfigurable
data flow at the beginning of 2017
so they had you know a fancy hardware
with 15 000 cores running at 6.7
gigahertz with
a lot of engineering complexity that is
able to have both slow memory and fast
memory and all that
but
from what i understood that the ceo uh
interviewed and say okay we were not
able to
succeed in it because it was so complex
that
you know going from the basic cases
where we were able to showcase a few
kernels trying to generalize that to
more complex and real-world application
we found that that our
you know hardware software stack had to
solve intractable problems and that
would become
unreasonable
so
i would say that their problem was that
they were
way way ahead of the curve you know
people are just exploring these problems
and they were not
able to estimate those difficulties you
know they were pioneers but
ultimately you know it didn't pan out so
great for them because eventually they
uh you know they filed for bankruptcy
there there's also this concept of um
in memory compute or near memory compute
uh what does what is that about
so
there are several
notions of how close the compute and
your memory should be
so one form of near-memory compute is
saying that you have
you have your memory model and from that
you're loading it to
what we call a software control scratch
pad memory so you have small fast
memories you can think of it like as a
processor cache
but their software control uh you know
traditionally a processor cache like in
the fondue one model is basically trying
as has a heuristic of you know saving
the most recent accesses just because
this is like the hot data yeah and
a software defined scratch pad memory is
something that is more compiler
controlled that you know
how you're going to be able to access
you know one of the things that you're
um
that
the one of the guiding principles of
devising an accelerator is that you're
basically able to anticipate how your
memory and data accesses are going to be
like you're going to have a a basic
a handful of basic computational
structures that they're going to iterate
over a lot of data and it's going to be
really recurring that's one of the
things that enable you to develop an
accelerator in the first place
so a scratch pad memory is a very small
a fairly small and fast memory you know
it can be kilobytes like
a megabyte
uh of data that is really close and it
sits and it sits within the same piece
of
uh
not even a piece of silicon but within
the same core within that piece of
silicon
and you'll be able to communicate that
that that data fast it will take like
one or two clock cycles
another approach would be
a processor and memory approach that
when that's when the processing element
sits really close to the actual memory
model if you're if you're going to
manufacture something like a dram or
something that is called memristors
which are memory based resistors you're
going to be able to manufacture a
memory module
that is going to have
logic elements inside of it
and you can see of those examples like
mythic or uh one of those companies that
are developing what we call the
processor in memory
is the idea that you can do that you can
look at um
that you can look at deep learning
computation and you can look at the dot
product and from that you can do analog
computation but that and and that will
be fairly fairly complex but the idea is
that you don't really need to
fetch back and forth data from the
memory because it's all within like the
special circuitry that sits within your
memory module
and you're saving a lot of that uh
energy going back and forth from uh the
memory chip and into a different chip
which is the
uh memory that the compute memory the
compute
uh processing element so it's it's like
it's essentially like having
a lot of like given that we already have
a lot of cores that we also have like
lots and lots of registers at those
cores but the registers aren't just for
you know
temporary data but they are actually the
memory
yeah okay so it's in a sense you can
think about it as you know the
difficulty is that you needed to really
change the memory that you're
manufacturing it that's something that
not a lot of companies are doing but
it's a promising direction because you
know if if you have something that is
more
that is less depending on your
transistors so it's less prone to the
failures of moore's law so that the the
end of moore's law
is
might not be the bottleneck for some of
these modules but there are other things
like you can see that there's like an
analog to digital converter which could
be power hungry and that creates a slew
of analog compute problems
so
there are also a bit more is let's say
call them esoteric uh things that you
all of these were already esoteric to me
um but they are there are more more
esoteric things like there's like
optical computing and neuromorphic
computing and things like this what are
you do you have any any favorites there
or anything that you think is promising
and not buzzwordy
um i think that
these like i think that light matter
is a company that is was founded by a
few uh mit graduates
and they have this idea that
light that representing analog
computation via light
could be
more efficient than using it basically
but then expressing it through the
digital domain it's an interesting
problem i i'm not really versed on the
uh different types of difficulties there
but you know it's
sort of like thinking about
an analog neuromorphic model where where
the brain
acts basically like on on
on analog pulses so this is a little bit
more trying to mimic the way that the
brain works than you would go
traditional uh
you know artificial neural networks
where you're gonna have a bf 16
represent your weights
and you can say that this is closer to
reality
and it's also more energy efficient but
you know these are
you can say that these are more advanced
technologies so i would say that
they're probably have their own set of
challenges
and uh you know you you never know which
one of these technologies will prevail
and be
yeah you know the winner
and what is what is neuromorphic
computing
i think that the neuromorphic computing
as the way that we know it is is the
form of analog computing you're gonna
have
data over here you're going to have like
the weights that are sitting within in
your memory and your activation is going
to be coming from that memory from
as as inputs to that memory you're going
to be able to do an analog
addition and you instead of doing that
dot product between the weights you're
going to have a single dot product doing
vectorized compute in an analog fashion
and you're going to be using
analog circuitry to compute the results
so it's more of a i would say it's more
similar in theory to the spiking neural
network uh model where you're gonna have
like your brain act on electric pulses
so that's what these circuit that's what
these solutions are are trying to mimic
yeah okay conceptually
um and you know that eventually
if you look at hardware from from you
know the grand scheme of things you know
you have those accelerators these
accelerators are good at doing ai but
you know if if you're looking if you
really want to get into the definitions
you know you can go you can look at the
in good fellows deep learning book it's
not really ai there is the a there's a
venn diagram where ai and inside of it
there is machine learning and then roast
present work presentation learning and
then there's deep learning and from
within that deep learning you can say
that these accelerators
are
are good at you know a subset of deep
learning and a subset of ml
that is good at
doing matrix multiplication you know
they're really good at doing things like
conv and transformers
but is that a general solution to ai no
one really knows you know you can say
that
the the interesting thing is that
because a hard the hardware was a key
enabler it's also
sort of
used as a limiter to what you can
achieve you know people are saying is
attention all you need is conval you
need
could be but for what thing but one
thing is for sure is that it's it it
consists of most of what your hardware
can do you know your hardware is really
good at transformers and and attention
and cons
but
you know if there is is that how
intelligence really work
maybe there's a huge
uh slew of applications
that can mimic more human intelligence
that are not
if that cannot be efficiently ran on on
hardware accelerators
um the way that they're built today and
we're not going to be able to explore it
just because we don't have the hardware
for it and we don't have a way to run it
efficiently yeah so it's an interesting
problem i mean there is this this
concept people say this right this is
this is a sentiment that's echoed
throughout the community that for
example graph neural networks uh we
don't have good hardware for graph
neural networks and therefore probably
we're not going to explore them as much
which also means that hardware
manufacturers since
you know we can't demonstrate that graph
neural networks are really good uh
won't build
graph neural network chips do you do you
see this do you see it generally going
let's say more and more converging on
some applications or do you think okay
we'll discard some of the applications
but also the ones we have will sort of
morph and develop into different
variants and so on like how do you see
how do you see the hardware
essentially the expensiveness of
manufacturing hardware's effect on the
diversity of the ideas in the field do
you think there is hope to to increase
diversity even with the cost of hardware
it's an interesting question i would say
obviously money makes the world go round
if there's money within these
applications you're going to be able to
bear the the build the hardware for it
the thing is like we said earlier
hardware is being a key enabler for what
you can achieve
and basically if you cannot
run your application on hardware it will
be it will be hard to create that
ecosystem for that application
to be able to justify building
specialized hardware for it so it's a
bit of a chicken and an egg problem yeah
if i were to develop an
an accelerator for
a non-euclidean set of problems i would
first need to look for the applications
for it i will need to be looking for
that justification for it simply because
you know i'm if if i'm a startup company
i'm going to have to need funding for it
right
but if you cannot have heart if you
don't have people that are exploring it
just because there's no hardware for it
you won't be able to find that
justification so it's a bit of a chicken
and an egg problem
so as i said you know
maybe attention is all you need maybe a
convince all you need
for surely it's most of what we have
right now
and it would be interesting to see you
know i would say that
as i said in the final thoughts i would
think that
in the
next
two or three years or so
the things are gonna become clearer and
and and architectures are gonna be able
to stabilize just because we understand
the problem better yeah you know it
takes us it would take us like four or
five years to really
converge
to a set of
common practices and the way that we're
developed developing hardware the well
that way they're we're developing
software libraries and the way that
we're developing compilers we're going
to be able to have like this
i would say like three or four stable
software stacks
that are really good at the con and
transformer games will there be other
models
to create other stacks sure you know but
if i were to start a startup today it
would be really hard for me to go for
you know the con and and the
transformers just because you know this
is saturated field and people are doing
it fairly well and you're basically
almost maximizing what you can do on
your hardware yeah
you have a
the last the last saying here in your
final thoughts is um
everything old is new again do you wanna
anyone explain what that's about
yes
so there are a lot of
it seems like there's there's a bit of
you can say that
on one hand
these
models
have been that the most popular models
those key enablers those alexnet and
those resnets those attentions and
births and the gp3s they all originated
in academic uh papers right
but in the hardware field
things are
there's a little bit more of a
disconnect
i would say that there are a lot of
papers there like there are dozens
of papers presenting new ideas every
year and the top conferences are the
esca hpca ask plus and micro
and
but eventually you can see that all
these fundamental
all these
accelerators were basically are using
origin ideas originated like 30 40 years
ago processing and memories was i was in
the 1980s vliw again to 1980s systolic
arrays the 1970s data flow programming
is the 1970s
processing in memory also like 1970s so
it's a bit of conservativism because
you know
as you as as you can say that
a company building hardware knows
at least in the older days where it was
hard to get money funding for it
you would need to really really justify
and really go for these well hashed out
ideas before you would go for those wild
card ideas and and and once you once you
have that
my you might be able to explore
more
revolutionary ideas
unfortunately i think that at this point
a lot of your architectural foundations
are already established so you won't be
able to explore this crazy accelerators
or those
things that are
you know really really out there you'll
be able to
somewhat integrate it into your existing
architecture
but it would be very daring
to go and break your entire architecture
completely and and especially in a very
competitive landscape
you might not be able to
go for that risk
you would be surprised but there are
many people in the ai community that say
that all the ai ideas have been had in
the 80s and 90s as well and there's
essentially nothing new under under the
sun
but it's a debated position
position well you know i i would say
that
for one thing for sure you know that
going back to the uh
attention is all you need and convince
all you need and essentially is what you
got you know a lot of these
you know the basic computational
structures
are already there you know people are
building on these on the baseline of
these architectures simply because you
know
one you know for me as a hardware
architect from that my perspective this
is what the hardware can do it even goes
back to the this academic notion of
accelerators there's a work called
stream data flow acceleration
that was presented in isca of 2017 that
they're saying okay
the acceleratable domains
need to
you know they need to fulfill certain
properties they need to have like a
fairly confined
um control flow they need to be like
fairly repetitive you need to know how
the data we use you need to know
a lot of
how your computation patterns behave so
you know if you're not going to be able
to
if you're not going to be able to build
an accelerator that completely
breaks out from this common wisdom and
and and breaks out this template you
might not be able to have
an ai model that behaves that way
is it is it true or not you know
could be or could be not maybe maybe we
will find out that
our existing patterns are fulfilling
enough i i would say that there are a
lot of problems within even within the
existing architectures that we were able
to
fully explore cool is there anything
else you'd like to want to give people
on the way i guess there's not an easy
way to necessarily get into you know
hardware yourself at home or something
but um if if people want to want to dive
they can certainly go to your articles
which i think are great i will obviously
link them in the video description is
there any any message you want to get
out there regarding this
i would say you know
i cannot really say anything about
looking at the blog try to look at high
level overviews of of how hardware and
software behaves
it's really tightly coupled today it's a
really exciting time to be
either an ai or in hardware because
it's a really great opportunity from
many aspects historically
that
you can explore ai hardware either
as a research scientist
as a data scientist
or even a computer scientist
it's really good to see how the how all
these pieces pan out
start looking at the high level
overviews and then just deep dive into
any of them you know open a computer
architecture uh book you know the old
ideas are already there try to look at
you know the high-level white papers
from the big companies you know the
googles and the nvidia's you know and
the some of the accelerator companies
try to understand how
your software behaves
and you might find out that
it's
really great that you can execute your
models much faster that you have
anticipated you know because
if you're
if it's gonna take for you to three days
to train your model
versus if it's gonna take you three
hours to train your model that's gonna
be a whole it's gonna be a key enabler
to a lot of your capabilities yeah so
just try to do all those tweaks try to
understand the common practices try to
follow programming books
and rules and best practices and you
might find out that
you're going to be able to be a kick-ass
data scientist
excellent well adi it was a great
pleasure having you here this was i
learned i learned a lot like really i
had no clue before this so thank you
very much for these articles and thanks
for being here thanks a lot for having
me
[Music]
you